MIRIAM PROSNITZ: My
name is Miriam Prosnitz,
and I was on Team Heatwave.
You play and there are
characters who move around.
And different people
who are at risk
for being vulnerable
to heatwaves
move around the screen.
So one person was in
charge of researching
who are those people?
And another person
was in charge of OK,
I'm going to make
a character object.
And we split up all
of those, actually,
right at the
beginning so that we
knew who to contact about what.
And then, based off of that,
we would come together and say,
what needs to be done, and
whose job is it, and is that
still balanced in terms
of who's working on what?
And it worked out
really well actually.
Actually, funny enough,
I took this course solely
because I had no computer
science courses this semester.
Because I was
abroad last year, I
did a full year of
engineering coursework.
And I was like, don't need
any more requirements,
might as well just
take one for fun.
So here I am in
Creating Video Games.
And so my goal was to write
code, and the funniest thing--
and I'm not representative
of my team at all--
I'm like the one
person in this class
who has not written
a single line of code
this entire semester,
because I ended up
being project manager a lot.
And so what I learned is a
lot of the process-- a lot
of making things
work, is really just
emailing people, calling them
on the phone, being like,
are you supposed to be at
this meeting right now,
going and buying
snacks for a meeting.
You think it's like
silly, you know,
nobody really needs
to get snacks.
But I've been told
by my teammates
that if I hadn't gotten snacks,
they wouldn't have come.
So--
I learned a lot about
the project management
and the work that goes on
behind the scenes, which I've
seen before, but I just
didn't realize the scale of it
in games.
Something I would give
feedback about this class
is I really like the fast pace
of the first three projects.
And this project, because
it was so much longer time,
the team was so much larger, and
we had this kind of set topic
we had to deal with, I
didn't enjoy it as much.
As I mentioned, one of the
main issues for our team
was passion.
At the end of the
day, I can summarize
what you should do in a
heatwave in like two sentences.
That doesn't make for a
very interesting game.
So that's something I would
say, if I was to do it again,
I would've played the game where
you play with the heatwave,
and you try to attack
people, because that
sounds like more fun.
And I think that's
the other thing
I learned about games--
that you really have to care
about what you're making.
Somebody mentioned in
one of the presentations
that for the last project we
would submit these sprint task
lists, and they
wouldn't necessarily
be what people
actually would do,
because people were so busy
at the end of the semester.
For my team, if it was the case
that we hadn't done something,
I would put it on the
sprint task list again.
But I didn't have to, and
if I hadn't done that,
then there would've
been a big divergence
between what we
said we were doing
and what we were actually doing.
So as an educator,
I would really
say check-in on your team.
See actually what they've done.
Make sure they're
setting realistic goals
and following through on them.